Well.
Hello everybody.
Thank you for coming.
Thank you.
For those of you who aren't in the room that are tuned in,
um,
it's a particularly exciting day today.
We have Janet mock here with us and for those of you who don't know,
Janet,
she is a New York Times bestselling author.
She is a trans advocate.
She is a glad award nominee.
The list goes on and on and on and on.
And I will learn a lot more about her as this goes on today.
So I'm Janet,
welcome.
Thank you very much for coming.
Thank you for having me.
Totally.
Okay.
So I thought it would be fun to start with some rapid fire questions and,
uh,
did you introduce yourself?
Oh No,
I did it.
I'm Michael Baloney.
No,
I work at Google.
I do marketing for Google docs and thank you.
Yeah,
that's so cool.
All right.
Now that,
that's out of the way,
um,
your favorite New York City's season?
Um,
spring.
Okay.
The fashion trend that you hope is dead fashion trend,
uggs,
the favorite place that you've been on vacation.
Okay.
Um,
this has to be going home to Hawaii.
Okay.
And the last place you want to vacation Sarasota,
right?
Um,
dogs or cats or other dogs.
Okay.
Um,
the golden girl you most relate to?
Oh my God.
Sophia [inaudible]
a living person that you haven't met that you dream to meet?
Hm.
Toni Morrison.
Okay.
Um,
do you have a current TV show addiction?
Oh my God.
I'm like trying to figure out which ones I just finished.
True detective.
I'm not obsessed with it.
Okay.
But I think one of those like revenge,
which just kind of a bizarre obsession because it's like so bad,
but it's so good.
Totally.
No.
Yes.
Okay.
Um,
Aretha Franklin or Patti labelle.
Patti.
Okay.
Uh,
I saw that shade.
Yeah,
that's what I see through.
And her,
she was like,
I'm not touching your hand.
You're on and Patty's team.
Yes.
Okay.
And uh,
for breakfast we are savory and sweet.
Okay.
And then your favorite Janet Jackson album that is not the velvet rope.
Um,
control.
Okay.
Excellent.
All right.
Now that,
now that that's out of the way,
um,
let's talk about,
well,
I think it was super exciting for you right now.
So before we talked about the book itself,
um,
you've been obviously the New York Times best seller just happened.
That's huge.
Um,
personally it was just your birthday.
So happy birthday.
Um,
the books doing amazing.
you know,
what,
what do you think is the highlight in the last few months for you personally?
I think it's meeting people around the country and kind of sharing space and
stories and intimacies with strangers because I think that the bizarre thing
about writing in a genre like memoir is that everyone knows so much about you,
but you know,
no one I think about else.
Um,
and so I think that there's this,
um,
and it's especially with just the platform of books,
period,
there's such intimacy there.
You have to really engage with it for long periods of time,
right?
Like you have to,
it's not like an article that you can skim real quick and kind of read the
headline and maybe read the first two paragraphs and be like,
I really got that,
you know,
like a book.
You have to really sit there with it and share space with it.
And,
um,
I think a book is open as mine is in terms of intimacy.
It builds this,
it's real,
it's an authentic sense of intimacy.
But when you're sharing space with people and you don't know anything about them
and they know so much about you,
you know that they can remember your best friend from childhood and you're just
like,
okay,
you know.
Um,
and so hearing people come back to me and telling me about themselves,
writing letters to me,
I'm telling me the points of intersection of resonance in the book with them.
Um,
that struck them.
That's always,
that's been the most valuable,
I think interactions and exchanges after post writing the book.
And I'm sure there's a ton of that.
I mean,
I know just sitting with you earlier,
we were already hearing from lots of people since you've been here.
It's pretty incredible.
Um,
so let's talk about now the process of writing the book.
How did it start?
Are you a journaler?
Like do you like how did,
what's your process?
It definitely started through journals,
I think.
Um,
before it was redefining realness.
It was just kind of my daily thoughts about,
um,
stories from my life and memories.
And so they weren't really even stories that they were just like fragments of
memories that I knew that I wanted to like have a record of.
Um,
and so there are also informed by my daily interactions with self meaning,
um,
this is before I stepped forward and Mary Claire,
which I did in 2011 and kind of told part of my story.
And so sitting there telling myself my own stories,
um,
was a way for me to,
I guess,
strengthen myself a little bit and get ready for public consumption that comes
from the public space of being visible.
And so it very much started from daily journals.
And I was,
at the time I was reading something called the artist's way.
So it was,
I dunno if anyone knows Julia Cameron's book,
but I was doing morning pages like faithfully.
And I was single at the time,
so I had lots of time to myself.
So girl was naval gazing for days.
Um,
and so it was very much from that process.
And then it grew to not only wanting to write my story,
but then talking to people in my life,
my boyfriend who came into my life at the time,
um,
my best friend opening up to her,
then the next level was Marie Claire.
And then it was also politicizing my,
um,
experiences through,
well contextualizing them through a political and social landscape and really
making it more than just me.
So this memoir is very much birthed out of my process over the last four or five
years and then it finally came forward.
Okay.
No,
that makes total sense.
And I,
I,
I think that for me,
reading the book that people that I encountered were such a huge part of the
story.
Like you said earlier.
And I remember you mentioning,
think in the introduction
perhaps that you talked to a lot of them before you wrote for the book came out.
And so,
um,
what,
what does that like to have a conversation with someone?
I mean you deal with a lot of challenging relationships in the book.
So how does that,
was it particularly hard for someone,
um,
for you to talk about them in the book or just help us understand that process
of like publicly,
um,
telling your story that involves someone else?
Yeah,
I think for me,
like my parents were fair game because I,
because I could,
I did not get to choose them.
So I felt like that it was completely fair for me to write very openly about
their lives and their interactions with me.
My siblings felt a little more shaky for me.
And so I think I felt the most,
um,
obligation probably to my brother Chad because he spent so much of it.
We're only a year and 13 days apart.
So we're born,
you know,
very closely or belt birthdays are always celebrated very closely.
Um,
and so I felt the most obligation and sensitivity towards him.
And so that was like a tricky thing for me to navigate.
So I,
that's why I think that I spent a lot of time,
if I was going to write about someone a lot,
I made sure that I had their voice in the book a lot.
So I interviewed my mother,
I interviewed my father,
I interviewed my brother Chad,
um,
and interviewed my best friend Wendy.
And so those were the four people that I felt were very pivotal characters in
the book.
But it's weird say characters because they're actual,
you fall,
but for the reader it's a character,
right?
Because they don't really know this person.
They know this person through my lens and experience and interactions with them.
And so,
um,
yeah,
that's,
that was,
uh,
the,
the process of writing about people was people you love and care about,
right.
Is also a difficult thing.
But I think the one thing I learned with memoir is that it's not so much a space
for venting or revenge.
It's a space to really look at everyone in your life,
even yourself with the same brutal honesty and sharp criticism that you would
look at quote unquote villains.
And so in this book,
there's,
there's no antagonist to me.
I think that everyone's a full person in this book.
And I think that when you communicate that kind of nuance and complexity,
it gives a more true experience.
Like my parents,
my parents were like,
if you read the,
if you read redefining realness,
my parents were super messy and ill equipped and battled with drug addiction and
abusive relationships and you know,
both had tons of children that they didn't really have the resources to take
care of.
And so,
but I had to really look at how they grew up,
right.
In the same sense that I have to give sensitivity to how I grew up.
And so when I could look at my parents as more than just these people who were
my mother and father,
but as their own people who had their own struggles and failed expectations and
heartbreaks,
I could paint some more full portrait.
And so I hope to do that with each character or person in the book in which I
wrote it up.
Yeah.
I definitely felt like I got to know them very well.
And,
uh,
that was one of the favorite parts from me.
You have the book.
Um,
so after it came out,
had your relationships,
have you sat down and talked about the content about particularly people and how
has that shaped,
has it strengthened or hurt any of your relationships?
Wow.
Um,
I think that's the bizarre part is that my,
my parents were learning about me as a world,
was learning about me because I had never been so open with them about like
they're learning about their child.
Um,
talking about sexuality,
talking about like creating a space for the erotic,
talking about what she was doing with her body and you know,
the pain that they caused upon her beanie.
Me As still,
even as a memoir,
as I still have a hard time with I statements.
It's really bizarre.
So I think for my parents it was this weird sense of like,
I'm really fascinated by the story,
but the story is like about my child.
And so I think that's a weird space to be in as a reader.
You know,
someone that's so invested.
Uh,
the first person that read the book in process was my boyfriend Aaron.
And um,
he was just like,
wow,
you really told it all.
You know.
And I think that he also felt there was like this weird sense of like prince
charming ask like abilities that I threw on to him and he was like,
this isn't necessarily true,
but I can see,
you know,
like for him it's not,
it's not how he sees himself.
Right.
And so like,
I think there's this weird for him,
that's what,
that's what he took away from the book,
but he was just like,
oh wow.
It was really interesting to see someone,
I love so much their full story through their own perspective.
And I think it was the same kind of thread with my parents.
Like I finally had like a real in depth conversation with my father three nights
ago about the book.
Um,
and I think it was very difficult for him to get through the book because so
much of the first half of it is about his struggles.
And I was writing about it from my perspective as a seven,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine year old,
10 year old,
um,
and also his like gender policing of me as a child.
Let's talk about that for a minute.
So the one of the elements of the book that I thought it was particularly
intense or had to be hard for you was when he discovered your,
I guess,
alter ego.
Kesha.
And for those of you haven't read the book,
I mean maybe you want to explain.
Yeah.
Okay.
Kesha was,
and then I'll explain what happened.
Know.
So Kesha was,
um,
I invented her I think when I was 10 years old.
Um,
so my father had many different girlfriends and they all had children.
And so this one apartment that we settled in,
there's a teenage girl,
she was about 15 and I was about,
I think nine or 10 and she would always talk to boys on the phone.
And so she would use me to tell them,
you know,
that she's not home to lie to them.
And so one day when she actually wasn't home and there's this boy that she was
trying to avoid,
I was like,
oh,
you know,
Mikayla is not here,
but this is Kesha.
And you know,
Mckayla told me to talk to you.
And so like I was just kind of telling these tall tells and fantasies and
stories of like my would be life as a girl because I,
you know,
I was perceive to be a boy throughout my childhood.
And so at the time being this very feminine child,
um,
who,
who didn't yet know that she was trans,
I expressed my girlhood through this character of Kesha,
which felt closer to me than myself,
even though I knew that it was very much a role.
Um,
and so Kesha began on the phone and then Kesha went into real life,
um,
during my spring break of like 1994 three it was,
I just remember what a man was on and I really wanted to memorize salt.
And pepper is what a man,
which I did by the way.
And,
um,
I will not say any of it here,
but,
um,
and so,
that's a sign don't tangent,
but,
um,
yeah.
So I brought key shout to the real world and I was kind of,
you know,
my,
my little cousin Michelle,
who was like two years younger than me,
we went out and I developed a crush on a boy who really liked me and you know,
I had long curly hair at the time.
Um,
and so I was like,
oh,
I'm Kesha.
And we had this little like little flirtation,
very innocent.
Um,
and then one day when my father was picking me up on the last day of spring
break,
um,
the boy Jamie knocks on the door and says,
it's Kesha hair.
And then it creates this whole thing that you have to see play out.
Well,
my heart yours when I read that part.
And uh,
yeah.
So then I guess what happens next essentially is that your dad shaves her head.
And I think hair,
I mean,
to me it seems like it represented a way that you could express herself in a,
at a time when you weren't quite sure how or what was okay or comfortable and it
was very natural to you.
And,
uh,
so that,
I mean,
how did it feel?
It,
I imagined that it,
it really felt like it stripped you of that identity.
And then I know the process of growing it back and the Gumby you had like,
uh,
someone called you or something.
Um,
just tell me about that.
So like how,
what was your experience after that with your dad?
So I think it was the first one.
My father really truly saw me.
I think he saw me before,
but he like,
it was easy for him to deny it because other people didn't recognize or see.
Right.
So they're having this boy walk up into his sister's space and to say,
I'm looking for Kesha,
this girl,
um,
my father,
he needed to correct that.
And so for him,
he,
you know,
as you just explained,
he shaved my head.
And that was my only sense of,
um,
a physical embodiment of my girlhood at the time,
right of my true identity as how I knew myself into my father doing that.
He thought that he was erasing it,
but hair does grow back.
Um,
even though it was very traumatic at the time,
and I had to really go through it for a year and a half.
Um,
and it,
I think that it was just this moment where he was very confused and he was
battling his self and battling his own ideas of what gender is and what his role
as a father was to raise this child that he as his son,
that was his namesake and all of these kinds of things.
And so,
um,
I think that it kind of is symbolic of a lot of our interactions growing up and
you know,
that you see those little moments and he even threatens me like years before
that he'll cut my hair and it was always the big threat.
And so when he actually followed through on that,
um,
I think it was a major pivot for in our relationship.
And I think it's great that a year and a half later I basically move with my
mother to Hawaii and it's a completely different environment.
Right.
Okay.
Well,
yeah,
it also shows like also the agency of young people like the lack of agency often
in most homes where you don't have control over,
um,
having the resources and funds to buy your own clothes to say that you want to
do what you want and express yourself in dress,
in hair and makeup or adornments in any way.
And so a lot of times your parents are very much,
at least in the households that I grew up in,
it was very much,
um,
we have $100 $150 allotted to you at the beginning of the school year and we're
not giving you $150 are going with you to shot.
And so for me it was always like this pain time,
right?
Like,
it was like,
oh,
shout out to where all these damn JC Penney polos and like all this stuff that
you know,
and cargo shorts.
And I was like,
oh Lord,
I'd have to wear the stuff.
You know,
cause I have no agency to say that.
No.
And even know voice really to say that I don't feel comfortable in these clothes
and this is not what I want to wear and this is more,
and I didn't feel that safety in both of my homes to do that from,
you know,
until I was maybe like 13 or 14 years old.
Right.
I guess that's
no,
almost near the point where you met Wendy.
Right.
So,
um,
and,
and I think you guys together found ways to grab that agency and started buying
the clothes that you wanted to buy.
Right?
So tell us a little bit about that inflection point in your life.
Yeah.
That was,
you know,
this,
that relationship.
I think it's one of those things where people,
some people just come into your life at certain times,
you don't know why.
Right.
And so Wendy was just someone who really saw me.
Um,
firstly at school,
right?
Yes.
You saw me at school.
I was picking up,
my brother from school were waiting for my mom to pick us up from the little
playground that's between our two schools.
I was in middle school,
I was in the seventh grade and my brother Jeffrey is six years younger.
She is in the first grade and he was just playing and I was sitting on the
swings and when he was walking by with her green Bob and her high,
you know,
her super short shorts,
soccer shorts rolled up at her knee high socks and she just passed by with her
volleyball.
And she was like,
Mary,
are you my who?
And I was just like,
I didn't say anything because I wasn't ready for that sense of like reflection
and like recognition.
Like she really saw me and Molly who's a s uh,
I was in Hona Honolulu at the time.
So Ma,
who is this?
Um,
it's kind of a term that's,
it's like a third space for gender beyond the gender binary beyond male and
female.
There's a space to explore the spectrum,
but it mostly was,
um,
applied loosely if you bring the West are not western colonize sense of what
Mahu is.
It's loosely as transgender,
but that's not really what it is.
But it's kind of a space outside of the male female.
And it's oftentimes for children that are assigned male at birth.
Right.
Based on their parents of their genitals and who are feminine presenting.
And so when Wendy saw me,
that's what she saw even though I was wearing these polos and JC Penney.
Yeah,
she basically clocked me.
She spooked me.
She was like,
girl,
I see you.
Um,
why are you trying to pretend?
And I just ignored her and so I was not ready for her yet.
And here she is.
So visible.
Yes.
And looking for friends and looking for like,
girl,
I see you.
I'm going to come follow up later on.
When she did,
she followed up.
What,
what made you ready to talk to her?
I think it,
it's so deep.
I think growing up in a home where I always had this dream image of my mother,
right.
So like if we,
you have to really break down the family chronology.
My parents met a year later,
they got married and had me,
um,
and they already had children from previous relationships and they're fairly
young.
They're 23 years old.
Um,
and my mother already had two girls beforehand in my father had three children
from highschool,
messy.
Um,
and so then I come along the embodiment of what they believe is going to be
their life together,
their first marriages,
you know,
they're going to fulfill the American dream.
And he was a navy officer and she was,
you know,
this woman who worked in Honolulu and he's this black man from Dallas,
Texas.
And they meet,
that does not work out because my father's philandering ways.
My mother's just too high expectations from someone that she's not fully seeing.
Um,
and so they break up when I'm about three,
me and my brother go and live with my parents.
Um,
I live with my mother in Honolulu.
We stay with her for a couple of years.
Then she sends us,
because we need male influences,
her son's email influences.
So she sends it to live with my father,
who I live with for six years,
five to six years.
In that time,
I don't see my mother at all.
Um,
and my parents are both had the same parenting style,
which is out of sight,
out of mind.
And so I dreamt of my mother.
I had these huge dreams of who I thought she was.
They were,
you know,
Disney prone and very,
way too much imaginings of this dream girl in my life.
And so when I went back to Hawaii,
I thought it would to meet the good,
perfect son for her and like butch up and Wendy's like,
girl,
no,
that's not true.
I'm looking at you and I don't see that anymore.
And so I was like,
I'm gonna hold onto it for a little while more for my mother.
Right.
Cause I think as children,
that's what we internalize.
We,
if we do the right things,
if we are perfect,
then our parents will truly see us and love us and accept us and give us
everything that we want.
And so sorry to interrupt you,
but I remember seeing that it worked,
like you did so well at school and that kind of pride,
I think it was in line with what you're saying,
that's part of being the perfect child,
studying and getting good grades.
Oh yeah.
For sure.
And,
and so I think that I really,
I began and within that year I began really seeing my mother for who she was.
She was no longer this dream girl image of her.
She was herself.
And I think it,
it did not live up to,
no one can live up to the expectations you have in your head if someone,
and so from my mother there was a sense that she failed me and my child like
mine up in my adolescent mind.
And so I decided to just be myself after a while and I was like this pretending
to be someone else for her,
um,
is not working for me anymore.
And so that's when I accepted,
when these invitations a friendship and that's when we began going to the thrift
store and you know,
pulling stunts in the thrift store and like changing price tags for like the
color coded tag sales.
You know,
sometimes when you go on,
it's like the blue tags are 50% off.
And so we were very much like scheming and you know,
going in,
it was a mess,
but it was great.
You know what I mean?
It was like how we found agency with having very little resources.
We could go in with 10 to $15 and leave with tons of little soccer shorts and
high socks and shoulder pads for hip pads and all these kinds of little things
that we ended up doing and that we,
we carved out our own space for like womanhood together.
You know,
we develop that together.
Yeah.
And so,
and she's still in your life,
right?
Yeah,
she's still,
she's still my closest friend.
Um,
and I think it's,
it's very interesting.
We've like had points of,
um,
putting our lives went in separate directions at certain certain points.
I kind of write about it and when we came back to an adulthood,
really seeing each other again.
It's so great to have that shared history with someone,
but also just the sense that history also breeds so much intimacy because
there's nothing that I've ever had to explain anything to Wendy.
She just always has seen me and known me and affirm me and validated me and also
like nurtured me as a friend and like that's,
and I always think of like sisterhood and just good friendships in any kind of
relationships,
whether they're romantic or platonic or sisters or brothers or siblings.
Um,
that's the kind of relationship she's always had for me.
And I think of what a blessing that was for me to be a 12 year old,
to find that friendship and then to develop it and still have it now as a 30
something year old person.
Totally.
So in addition to the people in your life,
another theme that I saw come through was music as,
as something that you turned to me.
You already mentioned what a man,
but you know,
we,
I read about Aaliyah and I read about Toni Braxton and,
you know,
the list goes on.
I'm actually curious,
who do you think in today's music world would be the equivalent for a trans girl
to look up to or
that's important?
I think pop culture is so personal.
Okay.
So I think it's hard to say like,
I think some,
you know,
obviously trans girls,
it's,
we're not all the same,
so we would all like different kinds of music,
you know,
some may be into punk.
That's not my thing.
You know what I mean?
Like,
so I think for me,
I was very like pop B oriented.
So that's why when Destiny's child,
you know,
came out with like,
no,
no.
And bills,
bills,
bills and you know,
say my name and independent woman,
like that was like my life,
you know?
Um,
and like I have like,
I basically have a whole chapter dedicated to like my love of Destiny's child
and Beyonce because it,
it just shows how like media representations,
right?
Seeing yourself in media and someone else that,
whose experiences are completely different than yours,
but who just have something that resonates with you.
And I think that for all of us,
that's very personal.
But I think that for me,
I wanted to not only be literary in my references,
right.
Cause I talk about spending a lot of time in libraries and reading books by a
lot of women of color,
um,
like Toni Morrison and Alice Walker,
but also like these media representations of like Beyonce and Oprah Winfrey and
Diana Ross,
like,
um,
and all of these women just kind of gave me this whole composite of self that
really showed me.
So I think that's very personal,
but it's also very like shared to,
you know,
like I think we talked a little bit about,
um,
some of the points of pop culture,
you know,
yes.
Resonance for us.
Totally.
Exactly.
So,
uh,
have you encountered any of these women,
like since your books come out,
like have you,
has there been any kind of like crossover or have you met any of them?
No,
not yet.
Yeah,
Beyonce.
I have not met Beyonce.
This is your chance to make it.
Okay.
All right.
So I think we're,
we're getting a little bit close.
I have a few more things that we could talk about and then we'll open it up for
questions.
So,
um,
I want to talk a little bit about your girls like us campaigns.
So tell us a little bit about where that started and where is that today?
Yeah,
so it started,
um,
it started specifically on Twitter at first.
And so it was,
um,
a Hashtag of solidarity and space to share resources,
stories,
experiences,
and conversations between Trans Women and I started in March,
2012 and since then it's gone onto,
of course Google plus and Facebook and everywhere where you can kind of do
hashtags.
And so,
um,
tumbler you'll see a space for it and Instagram and all of these different
spaces.
So it's kind of like the social media campaign to claim space in virtual space,
right.
Which nowadays,
it's kind of real life space for Trans Women in a world where trans women often
it's not safe for them to leave their homes.
I mean,
I think that that's something that people don't often realize that um,
these social media platforms can be a lifeline for a lot of people who are
struggling with identity,
who are struggling with self,
who don't have validation and affirmation and real life friendships.
Because my experience is very bizarre that I grew up with a Trenton's
girlfriend.
Like my best friend was trans right at that.
I didn't grow up in isolation,
but most trans women grow up in isolation.
They're often the only ones.
And so to have a space for young and poor and all these different kinds of trans
women to come together and say,
you know what,
in this space on Twitter,
on Facebook,
on Google plus,
we can have a space that's our own that we can go to for a source of like
mirroring and reflections and sharing and sisterhood.
That's what girls like us has always been.
Um,
for me in my idea of what I wanted it to be,
I don't know where I'm taking it yet because I feel like there's just so much
going on,
but I,
I would like it to still,
I think that for me it would be creating a real life space for it.
And I think that it is still like a girls like us as a name and a,
and a brand is something that I want to have maybe for like a summer camp for
young trans girls.
Um,
that would be like my legacy project that I would love
to do with that.
Great.
Okay.
And then I guess one more question.
So it seems like a lately,
even in the last couple of weeks,
trans visibility is popping up in the media,
perhaps more than I have seen it previously that you were featured in the New
York Times article last week,
uh,
alongside a lot of other trans folks.
Uh,
we've got Laverne Cox and orange is the new black.
Um,
do you feel like there's some kind of turning point brewing or what do you think
is,
what do you think is next?
What has to happen next?
I think what has to happen next?
I think it's like,
um,
actions of true inclusivity,
meaning that Trans people are not these,
um,
objects to be gawked at and kind of say,
look at these trends superstars,
right.
That's a separate thing from us.
I think that we really need to have more and more spaces.
I think one that I would like to applaud that I was lucky,
lucky enough to be a part of and humbled to be a part of was the women's history
month.
Google doodle.
Yes.
Right.
Which included two trans women of color in it,
right.
And Asian American,
Trans Women and myself.
And that's,
that's the kind of actions that really need to be happening I think in media
platforms to really think about the points of intersection in which Trans Women.
For me,
trans women are kind of how I sent him a lot of my politic,
um,
how we can include trans women and their different intersections.
And a lot of these spaces because trans issues are not its own separate issues.
It's a human issue,
right?
We all have a sexual orientation,
we all have a gender identity and we really break it down in that way.
We,
we see people as more complex,
um,
more across the spectrum of just speaking across difference.
And so for me,
I would love for a big media moment to really happen where a media platform
takes,
um,
leadership and really sparking a conversation,
say like a Time magazine creating a cover to say that this is the next civil
rights movement.
This is something that we really need to begin really talking about.
Cause a lot of people do it as trend pieces.
Like trans people are having a moment now.
And for me,
my entire life,
trans people have been having moments,
you know,
it's just that you decided to,
you decided to pay attention now.
Yeah,
but like we've been having moments forever.
Like Christine Jorgensen was like around in the 50s and like,
you know,
um,
Carolyn Casie was around in the eighties and nineties on the Arsenio Hall show.
So none of this stuff is new.
Like it's kind of slick,
a call cyclical.
And I think it's just media that says that,
oh,
this is hot now.
And so I think our culture is ready to develop language and to really discuss,
um,
discourse with trans people about their actual lives and not so much about what
do to their bodies because that's been tried and true and done.
So I think that a lot of the reason why there's been a lot of discourse lately
is because Trans women have been at a point to say that the way that you're
reporting on my life is not cute anymore.
And so this is why there's an issue with this and why it's reductive and why
it's not enough and that,
yes,
and you need to see us as people.
I am a woman and that's who I am.
I happen to be trans and happen to be black,
but all of these things are a part of my experience.
And if you really want to engage with me,
please read my book first and then bring me on your show.
Hashtag shady queen.
Okay.
I,
you know,
this has been really great.
I could keep talking to you for hours,
but I won't.
Uh,
so it does anyone here in the room?
I have any questions.
Okay.
Oh yeah,
please use the microphone so that people on the livestream can hear.
Hi.
I don't really have a question,
but I just wanted to thank you for being willing to be in the spotlight.
Oh,
thank you so much.
Very helpful.
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
I was just thinking about how you were talking about being seen for who you
really are.
Do you feel like,
uh,
you know,
it's been difficult for people to see who you are.
Have you become very good at seeing other people for who they really are?
Was that difficult for you to,
okay.
I think I can only really see people if they allow me to,
um,
share space with their experiences and stories.
Right?
So for me,
I,
what I've learned in this entire process of being very visible is not to make
assumptions about people's identities are lives or pains or points of access,
um,
or exile and oppression.
And so for me,
like I think there's only so much you can tell about a person by just looking at
them.
Um,
and so for me,
I think that as a trans person,
as a person of color,
as a woman of color,
I don't make assumptions about people anymore just based on my vein interaction
with them or how I may perceive them.
And so that's the one thing that I think that,
um,
I wish that we all would do.
So that's why I appreciate when there's points of conversation in group settings
when we say that,
you know,
what are your pronouns are?
You announce those things so that we don't assume what someone's gender is.
Cause you never know just based on looking on people.
But I think that we've been,
we've grown up in a culture where we just kind of,
um,
we just assume people's identities and genders and that's not necessarily
something we should do anymore.
And I hope that that's what brings these conversations kind of spark and bring
up.
Um,
in terms of myself,
I find that oftentimes I'm invited to spaces and only expected to speak about
being trans.
Whereas I think that my experience is so much more than just transition.
Not that speaking about transits alone is something that I shy away from or
anything like that.
But I'm also a woman of color.
I'm also someone that grew up poor.
I'm also someone that as a teenager engaged in sex work because I didn't have
resources to have,
you know,
healthcare and all of these different things.
And I think that I can speak to,
but I'm not really called brought to the table to speak about that.
They're like,
Hey,
young woman,
we just want you to talk about being trans right now,
as if that's my only experience.
And most times when I navigate the world,
most people don't know I'm trans.
They often take me for a CIS gendered mixed black woman.
And what does that mean to be that kind of a woman,
someone that's objectified in the streets and all these kinds of different
points of intersection.
And so I hope that we can have deeper conversations about people's identities
and the true and what their lives and lived experiences are,
are actually like,
actually it could you define cisgender for those people who aren't familiar?
Sure.
Well such gendered is,
uh,
um,
so there's trans,
right?
I think most people understand what trans is and,
and sis is kind of the opposite in terms of a prefix.
So Trans Means,
um,
to cross and sis it's kind of like chemistry terms,
which is interesting,
but this is really getting inside baseball a little bit.
Um,
I don't even know what that means.
I just all of the often say that inside baseball cause I didn't even watch
sports,
but uh,
but cis means on the same side of,
and so they're kind of,
so when you're talking about CIS gendered or six sets,
this sexual or transgender transexual trans often means to cross insists needs
to stay on the same side up.
So often we were talking about relationships with,
um,
your assigned sex at birth,
which we are all based on the way that our genitals may look when we're born as
babies.
You're assigned a sex,
which is often different from your gender expression.
And so that's kind of for CIS people.
They oftentimes most likely identify with the sex and gender that they were
assigned with at birth.
So they stay on the same side of worse Trans People,
um,
cross that are perceived to cross some kind of invisible barrier that we have in
our culture about gender and sex and sex that's assigned at birth.
So I hope that I explained that well.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Okay.
Are there any other questions from the room?
Hey.
Hi.
First off,
thank you for being here.
This has been really great to watch.
There's this idea in the gay world,
um,
of guys or girls who can pass,
who,
uh,
you know,
guys might be masculine or might not look like the stereotypical image of what a
homosexual it looks like,
you know,
to society and whatever that means,
whatever that means.
But what it means in,
in day to day life is that they have,
they have to keep coming out in the workplace with new colleagues,
with new friends.
I have to keep saying,
Hey,
I'm gay by the way,
and this is who I am.
Um,
because you can't tell.
Do you feel like you need to keep coming out in your life?
Um,
and maybe now it's a little different cause you're in the spotlight,
but in general,
do you feel like you have to keep coming out about who you are?
Is that tiring for you?
And do you ever just want to just be a young woman and live and not have to keep
explaining who you are in life?
[inaudible] so for me,
I think that I write something that's a really great question.
I think that what we're talking about is also is,
um,
gender expectations.
And I think that's the link between,
um,
trends and lesbian,
gay,
bisexual people is this idea of gender expectations.
If you're,
if you're assigned male at birth and you're attracted to men,
that's not following the gender prescriptions that we prescribed in our,
in our culture.
Right?
And so oftentimes that means that to be a gay man that is feminine presenting,
right?
Then people,
oh yeah,
that he's gay.
Whereas you can be a completely straight man and also be feminine presenting.
Right?
But we're talking about gender expectations,
right?
So like when you said that a man who doesn't,
who isn't,
um,
seen as homosexual and as it continued to come out because he presents in a more
traditionally masculine way,
even though he's attracted to men,
which often is prescribed as something that women do,
not necessarily men,
which is very simplistic.
Right?
Um,
and so for me,
I do have trouble with that and I come out,
um,
and I disclose my identity as a trans woman for political reasons,
often my personal life,
I don't,
it's not something that I do every single day.
Um,
I don't feel like it's people's right to know my story,
that my story is mine to towel in spaces of intimacy and relationship.
And if I feel like telling someone,
then I do.
But I never feel an obligation to often in public spaces I do if the,
if the context is to talk about or to place me sometimes as trans.
So it's like,
so why are you in this LGBT space with this man?
Because you look like a straight woman.
It's like,
well,
I am a straight woman,
but I am a trans woman.
And so it's like really unpacking that for,
for people oftentimes.
But I don't feel an obligation politically.
I do.
And so I think that coming out or inviting people into your life is a
politicized movements that we all do in our personal lives.
And I choose to do that in certain strategic spaces,
but oftentimes I don't feel the obligation.
Yeah.
Thank you.
All right.
It doesn't look like there are other questions.
So I want to thank you,
Janet,
again,
for coming.
I want to let everyone know that redefining realness is available everywhere.
Books are sold,
and I encourage you to read it.
I read it twice.
It's excellent.
Um,
yeah.
So thanks again,
Jennifer coming.
Thank you for having me.
[inaudible].